[Music]
if you've ever been on a plane you know
that there are very strict rules on
board to make sure that everyone is safe
but that doesn't keep strange events
from happening just wait until you see
which animal people are allowed to bring
on board if this is your first time
visiting our channel don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we are showing you
the 10 craziest things people have done
on planes babies in overhead bins
overhead bins are the perfect place to
put your bags to make sure they don't
get in your way
and you can put babies there too
actually this is what you were supposed
to do in the 50s baby seats used to hang
from the overhead compartment the
parents had the chance to enjoy the
flight sitting comfortably in their
seats while their babies slept above
their heads unfortunately it didn't
provide enough safety for the child in
the occasion of turbulence the parents
now have to buy seats for their children
or let them sit in their laps for free
but people still put babies in overhead
bends nowadays and it's certainly not a
good thing to do in 2011 a flight
attendant from the Australian airline
Virgin Blue was fired for that they saw
a little boy playing peek-a-boo with his
father and tried to do something to make
him laugh the flight attendant picked
him up and put him in the locker
unfortunately no one thought that was
funny as the mother was crying the
father was in shock and the boy suffered
from anxiety and withdrawal the flight
attendant was fired and will probably
never try to do something a little crazy
to make a child smile we could say that
understanding what to do and not to do
with the child was over their head
flight attendants in overhead bins when
there are many passengers on the plane
you might feel like there is not enough
place for your bag in these lockers but
actually there is enough place for a
person to lock themselves there you
might not see a passenger doing it
during a flight but flight attendants
love to climb into the overhead baggage
compartment it's actually part of the
initiation of China's con Maine Airlines
flight crew after 30 to 50 hours of
service their co-workers forced them
into lockers when the airline found out
about this they said that they attached
high importance to the incident
it would make sure it doesn't happen
again however they weren't there to
listen to the new flag attendants who
complained that they didn't want to take
part in this ritual they felt like they
had to do this to be part of the group
even if they were not comfortable with
the idea of breaking the rules
fortunately for most of them this was
just fair time joking with each other
and the crew was very harmonious you can
see many flight attendants from
different airlines posting pictures of
themselves and overhead bends on
Instagram and it really is surprising to
see these serious flight attendants
acting this way we understand that after
a 12-hour flight everyone deserves to
have some fun scorpions on board when
you're on a plane you think that you're
in a safe and clean environment with so
many rules and safety measures
everything had to be taken into
consideration right but don't think that
you are safe from scorpions just because
you're up in the air
with the United Airlines these creatures
can fly in a flight from Houston to
Calgary a passenger was stung by a
scorpion
the creature fell from the overhead bin
and landed on a man's hair while he was
eating his lunch it fell on the dinner
table and as he was trying to grab it by
the tail the venomous creatures stung
him the scorpion ended up in the alley
where the flight attendants caught it
and flushed it down the toilet they
immediately consulted a med link
physician on the ground to make sure
that the man was safe and medical staff
were there to take care of him as soon
as the plane landed it's not clear how
the Scorpion even got on this plane but
many people believe that it came from
Costa Rica as the plane was in the city
the same day you might think that this
man is really unlucky after being stung
by a scorpion on a flight in the United
States but he is not the only one
another scorpion was found on another
United Airlines flight so unless you
like these little creatures you might
want to travel with another airline
while they find a solution to this
problem the emergency slide we
understand that after a 12-hour flight
the crew is really tired they might have
the chance to sleep in beds in the rest
area but this is not enough for most of
these hard workers and one United
Airlines flight attendant felt like she
didn't even want to do this job anymore
when she exited the
plain after a routine landing she just
decided to use the emergency slide to
get out of the plane she just opened the
door in play to the slide dropped her
back and slid down herself most people
will never see that inflatable slide in
their lives so it was really surprising
to see her using it so casually no one
understands why she did that except if
she really wanted to stop working and
was too shy to tell her boss that she
wanted to quit so according to this
theory she should be happy to hear that
she had been fired but she is not even
the first one who did that years before
a JetBlue employee announced over the
planes intercom that a passenger had
abused him before saying that he was
leaving his job and making his creative
exit on the slide we don't know what's
wrong with these flight attendants but
when we see how they react we think that
we should treat them in a better way the
smelly poo it usually takes something
really important for a plane to make an
emergency landing like a fire a
dangerous technical difficulty or any
life-threatening situation but some
would never thought that going to the
bathroom would cause so much trouble
during a British Airways flight during a
seven hour flight from Heathrow to Dubai
the plane was in the air for only thirty
minutes when the pilot requested to see
the senior cabin crew passengers knew
that something was wrong but they never
expected it to be that it turns out that
an excrete meant was smelling so bad
that a quite pungent smell was coming
out of one of the toilets as only fifty
percent of the air is recycled and
cleaned it became a health and safety
problem this is why they decided to
return to safety and comfort going back
to the airport to make an emergency
landing as the next flight was only 15
hours later all the passengers were
provided with hotel accommodation before
they rescheduled the flight to depart
the next day we can't imagine how
mortified the person was and we can't
help but feel sorry for their roommates
who have to go through that every day
they'll probably never want to use the
public restroom for a number two again
who thought that poo could cause so much
trouble snakes on a plane
no this is not only a movie but also
almost a documentary in 20
sixteen in a narrow Mexico flight a
large snake fell from overhead
mid-flight it was spotted on the ceiling
when someone decided to film it people
sitting around and immediately unbuckle
themselves to stand away from it before
the green reptile fell on the floor
surprisingly the passengers didn't sound
really horrified people were able to
trap it in blankets and the copilot
wasn't afraid to handle the animal that
wasn't so small after all the plane was
then given priority landing at its
destination so the passengers can be
evacuated and the Animal Control workers
could come on board the airline doesn't
understand how the animal even got on
board
but they are investigating to prevent
this from happening again but once again
this was not the last time a snake
decided to go on vacation in 2017 a
passenger brought a snake on an Alaskan
flight and forgot it on board after he
left the plane so they knew the animal
was there but didn't know where it was
it's a little boy who found it and
instead of panicking most people wanted
to see it a flight attendant was able to
catch it put it in the bag and put it in
the overhead then for the rest of the
flights now that you know about all
these incidents do you still want to go
on board we think we'll travel by car
instead a child hidden in a carry-on bag
we have heard a lot of stories about
people trying to find a way to travel
for free and we have to admit that we
also made a joke saying that we wanted
our friend to let us go on vacation with
them in their suitcase but a woman took
this seriously and let a child travel in
her carry-on bag on an Air France flight
from in Spain both to Paris the woman
was in the process of adopting a child
but couldn't wait longer to bring her
back home she first tried to travel with
her as a passenger but she was prevented
from boarding a flight with her this is
why she decided to hide the girl in a
bag and buy another ticket only for
herself different sources said the child
was between one and four years old but
she was certainly small enough to fit in
a little bag the woman took the carry-on
with her
place the girl at her feet on the plane
and covered her with a blanket but
passengers noticed her when she had to
go to the bathroom nobody could believe
it and they were talking amongst
themselves shocked by the incidents
the woman was later arrested and the
child was found in satisfactory
condition this was probably not the best
idea to prove that she could take care
of a child in the process of adoption
the cigarettes and at the cigars smoking
was allowed in planes for much longer
than you would have thought it seems
crazy to see everyone light up a
cigarette when space and air are limited
but in the 50s it was totally acceptable
for people to smoke cigarettes pipes and
cigars on board we can't imagine what it
was like for all the non-smokers who
couldn't breathe fresh air during these
long flights but we bet there weren't
too many of them at the time when they
thought that cigarettes were healthy
however people didn't have the right to
smoke at a terminal because they were
afraid it might ignite the fuel fumes
it's only in the 80s that smoking on
short domestic flights was prohibited
and people were not happy to hear this
then in 2000 all the flights in the
United States finally had to be
smoke-free this is really different than
what is happening today in May 2017 a
man was jailed for nine years and six
months for smoking in a plane toilet
after throwing the cigarette in the
toilet then it caught on fire and an
emergency landing was considered the
pilot who had been working in the
industry for 20 years said that he never
saw something so dangerous happen so if
you ever thought that smoking on a plane
wasn't so bad we hope that this made you
change your mind the emergency door do
you know what would happen if someone
opened the door of a plane during a
flight the cabin would lose pressure
extremely rapidly only this is enough to
end the lives of all the passengers
anyone near the exit would suddenly be
ejected into the sky and the plane would
start to break apart and these are only
some of the horrible things that would
happen if someone opened the door
mid-flight so it's surprising to see
that people actually tried to do this
during an Air Canada flight a man
attacked the crew with coffee pots and
tried to open the door mid-flight he
scared everyone when he said that it
would take one guy to take that plane
down and he wanted to take everyone with
him the man was quickly arrested but he
is not the only one who will try to do
that it's been reported that 12 Chinese
travelers tried opening emergency doors
in barely four months in 2015
no one understands why this behavior is
trending nowadays and it is certainly
scary but don't worry their plans are
always going to fail it is simply
impossible to open the emergency door
during a flight cabin pressure won't
allow it so you can be shocked if
someone ever has the intention to do
that but you shouldn't be scared for
your life unusual service animals we all
know that some people need to have a
service dog by their side because they
suffer from a handicap or a mental
disorder but some people are helped by
animals that you don't see every day
and they also have the chance to take
them on a plane for some airlines all
you need is a doctor's note and a
service animal registration to take your
pet on board this leads people to bring
many animals on the plane like miniature
horses capuchin monkeys or goats and
some of them can cause a lot of trouble
a support Pig was ejected after it
relieved itself in the aisle just like a
therapy turkey who caused trouble
flight attendants don't even react when
they hear that there are three service
animals on board they just hope they are
not too big
unfortunately this leads to many people
pretending to be sick only to take their
puppy on board and while some men and
women really do need a service animal to
be functional the others are not taking
it seriously and can have a negative
impact on how those animals are
perceived so don't forget that this is
not about fun but mostly about safety
have you ever seen something crazy on a
plane don't be shy to tell us what
happened in the comments down below and
that's it for 10 craziest things people
have done on planes if you want to see
more stories like this make sure to
watch 10 secrets flight attendants don't
want you to know thanks for watching
[Music]